michael starts off this hour in dayton
ohio hey michael how are you
hey dave how's it going it's an honor to
speak with you and ken
you too sir what's up hey so i've been
looking a lot at
cryptocurrency and i know you guys are
a little against it the it's pretty
hostile in that environment
i have about 3 800 saved up from
working my job and i just want to know
what are the best investments to really
look at and
where to go about it
um hostile what do you mean hostile
well hostile where the validity of it
were
the volatility yes oh yeah
definitely okay well i mean you you have
to set your
investment goals with what you believe
is your is your best path to becoming
wealthy otherwise you wouldn't do the
investment right
and so um how old are you
i'm 24. okay all right
so when i was 24 i made a lot of
mistakes
buying things that i thought would make
me wealthy
quickly and easily i bought a lot of
nothing down real estate i went broke
as a result i i bought gold
futures once a buddy of mine had a
uh stock broker ken a friend of his it
was a gold guy
and he had he had the ticket he had it
figured out he had the formula
and uh he had hit uh buying on the way a
future works
you purchase it at a price and if it
goes under that
if the if the price is under that when
you get to that date you get zero
if you go if it's over that then you get
a multiple of what you've put in
and so um i bought a future put five
thousand dollars in
that i didn't really have that's about
all i had put the whole five thousand
dollars in because this guy had hit
uh he had hit 14 times in a row on his
prediction
wow i mean he was amazing he was like a
gold savant he had it all figured out i
mean 14
times he had hit and the future made and
so
the rate we went in at i put five
thousand dollars in and it was a 10x
if it hit i was gonna make 50 grand it
was this 15th try
and we all know where i'm going with
this oh yeah you can you can see where
the story is going
you you know he missed on that try and
my my
my little bitty five thousand dollar net
worth was just evaporated
based on my attempt to make fifty
thousand in
ninety days off of five thousand um
and uh you know bitcoin's hot your
crypto's hot a lot of people making a
lot of money on it right now it is
as you said michael very very volatile
and so it falls
for me an old guy under the heading of
getting
rich quick and i have not found many
people that get rich quick
and so i and i don't like losing money
i mean i i just telling that story from
25
35 years ago yeah i would think so
i i i work too hard for the money that
we get and that we get to keep after the
government takes their share
and so i don't like losing it so michael
you can certainly do what you want to do
but you called here
we do not tell people to invest in
highly volatile
uh unpredictable investments
and currencies of any kind fall in that
category
bitcoin would be the most volatile among
those
uh crypto would be the most volatile
among those
and statistically um you're going to
probably get your
uh you know you you might get it i mean
the game stop thing when the kids were
running
the gamestop thing off of reddit that
was extraordinary and they they made you
know one guy called here he put in 3 500
bucks and he made 50 grand
his hit i mean he was playing he was
running running short on that thing and
uh you know with those guys they were
they took him to task he took them the
woodshed it was interesting to watch
from the outside
but i've also got a friend that's
invested in six restaurants and
i i i go over there and eat
yeah i didn't invest in any of them
that's right and i like the people that
run them but i you know you know what
the
failure rate on restaurants is it's like
almost all of them fail
yes you know they just don't make it and
so uh but he's inve he's an investor so
he wants to do that and that's fine i
don't i he called me said you won't put
money in this restaurant
i'll go over and eat i will invest in
your food
yes yeah because well it's really true
the way you teach investing
and the way i live and the way you live
that's right and that's how you base it
there is risk involved of course but
when you're talking about bitcoin
or really volatile stocks like this it
is i think it's no different than
gambling i'm not trying to be cute with
the words
but there's investing which is i'm going
to invest if you think about the way
that word is
then you talk about this kind of stuff
and it is a form of gambling it really
is
you're going all right i'm going to put
it in and hope that it keeps going up
but this stuff could drop
just like this out of nowhere at a
minimum it's speculating
not investing that's what gambling might
be on one side and speculation yeah
that's a bit of a strong statement
investing
investing might be but that's what
investing investing
implies the tortoise yes speculating
implies the hair
yes that's right gambling is the uh
possum in the middle of the road okay
but yeah that's what it feels like
emotionally to me
it really does like if i were to invest
in bitcoin i'd be a
got a better shot at bitcoin than you do
the lotto so that's all i'm saying that
is fair
but both of them are dumb ideas in my
mind and i
and i didn't put any money in either one
of them i've never bought a scratch off
ticket in my entire life
dave you're no fun no i just don't like
giving my money away
i can drive if i'm gonna have fun that
way i'm gonna roll down the window with
100
bills out and call it a traffic jam you
know what i'm going down the interstate
that's more fun yeah well you're too
competitive you want to have a shot at
making some money not just i'm going to
throw it in the air and to see what
happens
and you know of course everybody that's
a bitcoin genius right now thinks dave
ramsey's a out of touch boomer which is
probably true
but i'm also uh worth several hundred
million dollars so let's go figure that
out but um yeah i'd say look at the
scoreboard
take dave on all you want to but the
scoreboard is a scoreboard and it does
come down to
your risk tolerance what do you well not
just risk tolerance what is your goal
and what do the data points tell you so
i mean i've had people call this show
investing in beanie babies
really you remember when beanie babies
were crazy i was a kid i remember my
grandmother
people invested they were like they were
like such a hot commodity people were
investing in them
calling calling them as a collectible
calling in here saying i put my kids
college fund in beanie babies
i did that actually for me that's right
up there with bitcoin
yeah i mean you know i got a lot but i
did bob
the differences i did by beanie babies
as a gift [ __ ] no
sharon sharon got not not as an
investment but sharon
was collecting them as a hobby and now
okay that's good now the
grand babies and the shih tzu play with
them but they uh
that's all they're good for but you know
the thing is michael
you can invest in whatever you want but
the data points tell us that people who
do get rich quick
don't that's the bottom line
out of studying ten thousand
millionaires the number of them that got
rich quick
is very very very small
the ones that were methodical and boring
and didn't have a good story to tell on
their golf course buddy
when they're playing golf it's a fishing
story with some stock that they got into
they didn't have any of that they just
were methodical they were boring and
that's what i've done the second time
and the second time i cap it first time
i lost it all
you do what you want to do